In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for September 16th, on which we commemorate the Holy
Hyromarter Cyprian of Carthage, Thassius Caesilius Cyprianos was born of rich and noble pagan
parents in Carthage, near modern Tunis, between the year 200 and 210. He showed outstanding
ability in his studies and became well-known in Carthage to pagans and Christians alike,
as an upright and talented advocate, Rhetor. When about the year 246 news spread that he had
been won for Christ and baptized by the priest Caesilianos, it made a great stir. Cyprian immediately
distributed his goods to the poor and left for a quiet place outside the city, where he could
give himself to prayer and to meditation on the divine scriptures and church authors. In the
years 248 through 249, he was elected bishop of Carthage by universal acclamation of the people,
despite the opposition of some priests who were against choosing a man they regarded as still a
neophyte. Soon after Cyprian's election, the Emperor Ardecius unleashed his savage persecution of
Christians in the year 250. The pagan Carthagians who had never forgiven their brilliant Rhetor, his
treason, began clamoring for Cyprian to be thrown to the lions, but this was not then permitted by
the Lord, who will have us do good only when the time is ripe and rejects those who offer themselves
preemterally to the persecutors. So Cyprian fled with some other prominent Christians and remained
in hiding near the city for more than a year, keeping in touch with this flock by letter. During this
persecution, many people escaped torture and martyrdom by sacrificing to the idols or by signing a paper
certifying they had done so. When the persecution ended, these apostates, or lapsi, wanted to be
received back into the church, which presented the pastors with a serious problem. St. Cyprian would not
accept the proposal of those indulgent confessors of the faith, who were for the immediate reconciliation
of the lapsi. But neither would he agree to deprive them of all hope, of salvation, for the Holy Spirit
had shown him that the truth is a royal road that keeps clear of extremes. His decision was that
the lapsi should undergo a long period of severe penance, life long for those who had voluntarily
sacrificed. But if persecution broke out again, they could be restored to the church by the Eucharist,
so as to be strengthened for impending contests. This position did not satisfy Felicimos and the party
for immediate reconciliation, who, finding allies among the priests opposed to Cyprian's election,
set up Fortunatos as schismatic bishop of Carthage. Novatos, who had been the first leader of this group,
left for Rome, where he joined forces with the extreme supporters of Novation against Pope Cornelius,
whom Cyprian supported. The Holy Bishop's other opponents, those refusing the lapsi any reconciliation,
joined Maximus the Montenest, who also had himself declared bishop of Carthage.
The schism was brought to an end by the terrible plague that ravaged the empire and the city of Carthage
in the year 253 and 254, and which was the occasion of renewed persecution of the church.
Cyprian's holiness and love for his afflicted people were shown to the full during these tribulations.
He organized help for the sick, comforted those who lost relatives, and encouraged others to persevere
in faith and hope. When peace returned Cyprian called three councils at Carthage
in the years 255 and 256 to deal with the problems affecting the church, especially whether to reconcile
heretics by baptism or by simple laying on of hands as at Rome. Despite pressure from Stephen,
Pope of Rome, Saint Cyprian maintained the tradition of the African church and of the churches of the
East, especially that of Saint Fermilian of Cessaria, of baptizing heretics who wanted to be
reconciled to the church. But he refrained, unlike the Pope of Rome, from trying to impose this rule
on churches that had a different tradition. As it was, Stephen's intransigence resulted in a
breach between Rome and the African church, which was not mended until the Pope's death, in spite
of the attempt at reconciliation made by Saint Dionysius the Bishop of Alexandria.
In the year 256, when this dispute had still not been settled, the emperor of Valerian began a new
persecution during which Cyprian was arrested on the 30th of August in the year 257, and exiled to
Kurobiz, southeast of Carthage, where he set about getting help to the Christian prisoners
in the dreadful minds at Seagus. A few months later, he was able to return to Carthage, but he knew that
the time was approaching to confess Christ with his blood, for it had been shown him in a dream
that he would soon be arrested. Indeed, a few days later, he was indicted before the new
Proconcil Galerius Maximus. The Holy Bishop did not seek to defend himself, and hearing that he was
to die by the sword simply said, Deo Gratias. Thanks be to God. When the large crowd of assembled
Christians heard the sentence, there was a great commotion. They all shouted, us too, behead us with
him, and the whole throng escorted the martyr to where he was to suffer. When they arrived at the
place of execution, Cyprian took off his cloak, knelt in prayer to the Lord, and gave his
delmatic to the deacons who accompanied him. They calmly awaited the arrival of the executioner,
to whom the bishop ordered 25 gold pieces to be given for his trouble.
He put on the blindfold with his own hands, and was beheaded in the joy of departing to the
mansions of the righteous on the 14th of September in the year 258. St. Cyprian's writings, which
consist mostly of letters and short treatises, are among the most important in Latin-patristic literature
for the doctrine of the Orthodox Church. Through the prayers of our holy fathers,
O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, of mercy on us, and save us.